NFL Network analyst Kurt Warner one of
six Hall of Famers on the staff beset
NFL network carries the Texans Panthers
preseason game live tonight at 7:30
Eastern Kurt Warner Rams Giants
Cardinals great congratulations Kurt
thank you Sam I appreciate it
didn't I say that I was going to help
you get in the Hall of Fame a little
while ago what you told me that it's a
way back when he said that I wasn't a
hall-of-famer but if I got the Cardinals
to the Super Bowl you were going to get
me in so you you held up to your part of
the bargain I'm not sure what you did
but but somehow I got in and I give all
you always got it only wait wait you had
a chance to give me a lot of credit you
had a speech that went 20 minutes well I
just figured you you all you get all the
credit more than mine so I wanted to I
wanted to focus on the people that don't
get much credit and you and that's in 20
minutes and then there's a scroll at the
bottom I mean you didn't have to mention
Brenda your wife what do you want what's
on the scroll know what's on the stone I
told them to put you on the scroll then
how many times did you practice that
speech um a few times you know I've been
spend a lot of time shaping it and
directing it but I practiced it
probably half dozen times 10 challenged
Navy where's the jacket right now it's
it's still in the bag that I packed it
in front and I haven't unpacked yet okay
now been crazy busy working for the
network and we got high school football
practice that we do at 5:00 in the
morning so I'm still trying to catch up
on sleep so right now it's it's still in
with us I'll be taking it out pretty
soon
what changed when you set off a
firestorm where you said you wouldn't
have your kids play football a couple of
years ago and then everybody you know
was quoting you after you said that but
here you are you know involved in high
school football did anything change with
your opinion of football for your kids
no I mean it didn't change I mean and
again I don't know if I specifically
said I wouldn't want them to play I
wouldn't let them play I want them to do
what they want to do and I'm very
involved with it because I understand
the risk of it
and I think like any parent if you could
completely eliminate every risk that you
your child had you would do it but
knowing my history and my past and what
the game meant to me and how it what it
taught me and the person that I am today
I wouldn't change a thing about my
career and now I'm just trying to make
my kids very conscious of of
communication of understanding you know
when they're injured how important it is
to communicate that I coach my boys so
I'm always watching I mean I have
another point last year in one of our
big rivalry games were I said my son
took a hit and he just wasn't quite
himself and I pulled him out of the game
and said you're not playing you know and
it's one football game and I'm going to
be here to protect you so I understand
the risk I'm going to encourage my kids
to do whatever it is if they're possible
made love but I'm also going to do
everything I possibly can as a parent to
make sure I protect them I watch out for
them and I do the best out there if you
ever have a situation similar to what
Brady had with Giselle where maybe you
tell your wife that but you don't tell
the team um yeah I mean I sure we all
have you know things that that we don't
think you know it's going to really
assess anything from a team standpoint
you know we all have bumps and bruises
we all get banged up at different times
you know you probably talk to every
athlete that's ever played and they tell
you yeah there was a time that I was
injured but I didn't tell anybody about
it because I figured I could still do my
job and I didn't need to alarm anybody -
yeah I don't think there's any question
most athletes but I'm sure that I have
numerous times you know let my wife know
I'm a my ribs feel like they're broken
but you know it is what it is and you
kind of just you just got to go through
with it and deal with Drew Brees went
the other way he said he would not tell
his wife he wouldn't want to scare if he
if he had a concussion he said he
wouldn't tell her oh well I mean in and
I understand that other side of the
tooth is my wife's the first one to look
out for me and you know if I was going
to tell her anything she'd be the first
one to say hey you need to go to other
trainers you need to go make sure you
take care of yourselves and that's what
you expect is that you know just like I
said I'm going to do everything to look
out for my son my daughter whenever
they're doing anything I'm going to
alert everybody I'm going to make sure
they're taken care of themselves
our wives are going to do exactly the
same thing
he's Kurt Warner the Hall of Famer NFL
Network analyst tonight on the NFL
Network it'll be the texans and the
panthers we had LaDainian Tomlinson on
yesterday and I said who does Christian
McCaffrey remind you of guess who we
picked let me talk him Silas Marshall no
he because I said does he remind you a
little bit of you and he said no because
you know what I was playing for Marty
Schottenheimer and I'm running the a gap
they had me running up the middle and
you know Christian is not going to be
running up the middle and he said he's
more like Marshall Faulk I think he
meant you need to use him like Marshall
Faulk because there's only one Marshall
Faulk and that's not fair to compare him
that's high praise but you know how you
guys use Marshall can Carolina use
Christian McCaffrey the same way is Cam
Newton capable of doing that in that
offense well I think God becomes the big
question is first of all the thing with
Marshall was that he was in every down
back and so not only could we use him
out of the backfield and run routes and
attack linebackers and split it on and
do all that he can also run between the
tackles he was our best fourth and short
runner as well and so that's what makes
those guys different the David Johnson's
in the Marshalls but you're not just
putting them in to get them out in space
they can do everything so that to me is
a question would you be that guy at the
NFL level that can run between the
tackles stay in there on fourth down
task force act as well as get out on
route and then you mentioned the second
piece of that puzzle is Cam Newton
throughout most of his career that are
all sensing the way he kind is to make
the big droves down the field they're
not a stinking dunk team they're not a
team that uses their backs out of the
backfield
you know the throw at you they use them
to run the football and then they play
action and throw down the field so from
one standpoint you think well maybe it
makes things better for Camden because
some easier throws coming off the
shoulder injury but it's our dynamic
with timing and we're seeing the
linebackers that are on the inside
as opposed to just attacking the safety
down the field so that are the two
questions I have is Christian McCaffrey
and he you know complimentary back in
regards to the guy that just comes out
of the backfield and you do some gadgets
with him could you be an every down guy
in camera because game to be more of the
I'm a used Tom Brady for a larger best
people the dink and um five yards option
routes read that stuff too accurate
passes and move the football dot instead
of needing to do it what's out with the
big arm and the pictures on the field
well congratulations and good luck this
upcoming NFL season we'll check in with
you but great honor
great speech glad you gave Trent green a
shout out and I love the Dan Marino's
story as well but well-deserved curtain
thank you thanks all day and talk to
yourself nine that's Kurt Warner the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience